en directo a Vamos hasta Ecuador para
hablar con nuestro corresponsal Gustavo
Ortega sobre el arresto domiciliario que
solicitó la fiscalía general para el
expresidente Lenin Moreno Buenas noches
Gustavo quiero empezar preguntándole la
fiscalía general del estado de Ecuador
solicitó el arresto domiciliario para el
expresidente A qué se debe esta
formulación de cargos en contra del ex
mandatario teniendo en cuenta que
inicialmente se había solicitado otro
tipo de pena
Sí muy buenas noches para ti Juan Pablo
la fiscal general del estado ha
presentado los cargos enmarcados en la
investigación del caso sino hidro y ha
formulado prisión preventiva para el 37
involucrados 14 de ellos superan los 65
años por el cual estos ha solicitado
arresto domiciliario específicamente ha
señalado al ex vicepresidente de Ecuador
Lenin Moreno por haber recibido
beneficios económicos se habla según la
fiscal general del estado de un caso de
corrupción de 76 millones de dólares De
igual forma señaló que tan solo el
entorno familiar del ex vicepresidente
de Ecuador Lenin Moreno había recibido
beneficios económicos por
660.000 dólares ella hacía una detalle
de cuáles habrían sido los beneficios
económicos que recibe el entorno
presidencial el entorno del ex segundo
al mando de Ecuador y específicamente
detalló Leo textualmente la cita de la
fiscal general el vicepresidente
como su esposa habrían recibido 200
veinte mil dólares esto En beneficio de
un apartamento y muebles para este
apartamento de alicante De igual forma
también señala a su hija de haber
recibido cincuenta mil dólares a dos de
sus hermanos por Diez mil y trescientos
cincuenta mil dólares y De igual forma a
dos cuñadas y a la suegra quien señala
por beneficios de Diez mil quince mil y
cinco mil dólares esto es una
investigación por parte que realiza la
fiscal general del estado hace cinco
años involucrado en el caso sino hidro
Juan Pablo precisamente de eso le quiero
preguntar en qué consiste el caso sino
que involucra Lenin Moreno y qué medida
ha solicitado a la fiscal general en
este caso precisamente
pero el caso de servidor específicamente
es una trama de corrupción específica en
cuanto a la a la mega obra de la
Revolución ciudadana específicamente
habla sobre la contracción de un
proyecto hidroeléctrico la
hidroeléctrica de Coca codo Sinclair
digo ha presentado sobre precios la
fiscal general del estado ha dicho y que
involucra una sobreprecios porque De
igual forma fueron reportados aparte de
sobreprecio en múltiples fisuras que
desde su inauguración de 2016 no fue
entregada totalmente la obra se habla
aproximadamente de ocho mil fisuras y
daños en esta construcción pero poco a
poco a medida que va avanzando la
investigación se habla de muchos más
fisuras y daños en esta construcción De
igual forma Qué medidas ha tomado bueno
la fiscal general del estado ha pedido
la asistencia Penal Internacional a
diferentes países ha hablado de los
Estados Unidos Panamá Paraguay y China
Belice son tan solo algunos de los
países que ha pedido
Penal Internacional el ex vicepresidente
compareció el día de hoy a través de la
plataforma zoom él dijo que no era
responsable por parte de la contratación
de esas autoridades responsabilizó a las
autoridades del entonces para esta
contratación él ha dicho que no tenía
ningún tipo de responsabilidad de esto
Solo se encargaba de la misión espejo
Manuel espejo para el momento que era
vicepresidente de la República otras
medidas que ha pedido para el ocho de
marzo ha convocado al ex presidente de
la república Rafael Correa él no se
encuentra como uno lo señalados de
investigación de en este caso Pero ha
pedido su comparecencia para dar una
versión libre y voluntaria para extender
así las investigaciones en torno a este
caso